[Música]
foi muito bom dia e obrigado a sair para
a gente é de todos
primeiramente as minhas ideias uma
projeto e tem como principal objetivo é
aumentar o grau de adoção dos cachorros
e diminuía comercialização deles
ele também irá ajudar os adultos que não
têm onde deixar os seus cachorros e as
crianças que têm o sonho de ter um
cachorro ele irá conectar esses dois
lados a criança claro por meio de um
responsável
uma pessoa que também queira ter a
experiência de um cachorro mas já está
muito segura disse
com o adulto por meio de um épico que
irá chamar 1.6 bom
ultimamente muitos adultos não têm onde
deixar seus cachorros
muitas vezes locais de trabalho ou de
viagens muitas crianças têm o sonho de
ter um cachorro mas muitas vezes os pais
não querem o animal dentro de casa ou a
educação porque responsáveis ou pequenas
bom ea gente nesses dois programas de
encontrar se uma solução é bem simples
na verdade um projeto ele consiste
basicamente em esses dois lados e fazer
com que ele se comunique onde o adulto
deixe o seu cachorro na casa da criança
ou de uma pessoa para que ela tenha
experiência de cometer um cachorro
durante um dia ou período de trabalho
que ele vai do período de trabalho que
ele tem bom esse aqui não é disponível
mas aqui tem um esboço de como ele seria
nem cima tinha logo e na primeira tela
você irá ficar das trará colocando o
nome endereço e com a parte você quer
cuidar e já na segunda já aparece todos
os cachorros com cada uma das avaliações
e descrições desse bom para você tem uma
ideia melhor é do meu projeto e da minha
idéia eu fiz os passos que vocês deverão
seguir
passo um baixo epe passou 2 cadastre se
colocando o nome endereço e qual parte
você quer cuidar passou três lewis
avaliações e descida com segurança e off
off teriam assim web você poderá
conversar com ele e marcar um encontro
para massagem de seu cachorro por
exemplo o horário que ele corre você
precisa tomar alguma medicação
ou o horário que costuma passear
bom então o sr podemos concluir que ele
ajudará três partes os adultos porque
assim eles é terão ciência eram seguros
não deixar o seu cachorro com outros
cachorros já que ele seja muito bravo ou
o da os as crianças porque assim elas
provaram para os pais que são
responsáveis e talvez eles adotem um
cachorro onde no ep também haverá uma
parte só para adoção onde os pais
poderão adotar um cachorro minha o
animal para o seu filho e também ele
ajudará até os cachorros porque eu
imagino eu que deve ser muito mais legal
eles passarem a tarde com uma criança
que brinca que passei do que com outros
cachorros em um hotel bom agora fiz uma
platéia pra vocês
se você quer um cachorrinho mas seus
pais não querem esse é um problema mas
tudo tem solução
baixe o ep que todos os seus problemas
se resolverão um cachorro é possível
pode ser pequeno médio ou grande o que
importa é que ele caiba dentro do seu
coração e muito obrigada pela sua
atenção
[Aplausos]
[Música]